and I wanted to take this opportunity to
provide you with an update on the food
supply chain and the steps that we are
all taking to ensure that everyone has
access to the food that they need we
recognize that this is a challenging
time and that there are many things that
the government is asking the nation to
do differently as we work together to
fight this pandemic however there is one
message I want to start with loud and
clear this afternoon which is be
responsible when you shop and think of
others buying more than you need means
that others may be left without and it
is making life more difficult for those
frontline workers such as our doctors
and nurses and NHS support staff who are
working so hard in such difficult
circumstances
so as you shop think of those who are
finishing their late shifts and need to
pop to the local shop at the end of a
long day today the Prime Minister and I
have spoken to the retail sector there
is more than enough food to go around
and our food supply chain is able to
expand production to cope with increased
demand in the last week sales of some
foods have increased significantly and
manufacturers have produced around 50
percent more food than they usually
would there is no shortage of food
available and more is arriving at shops
every day but the challenge that all of
our retailers have faced is keeping
shelves stocked throughout the day in
the face of increased purchasing
behavior we all have a role to play in
ensuring that we come through this
together so the government has taken
steps to set aside rules restricting
delivery to stores and relaxed
restrictions on drug government Guard
reiver
hours so that more Goods can be
delivered to every store every day and
we have also set aside competition laws
so that supermarkets can coordinate
their efforts locally sharing staff
sharing delivery vehicles and
coordinating their store opening times
to ensure that food reaches every part
of the country we've also waved the
plastic bag charge and on Ahnold for
online purchases to speed up deliveries
our retailers and food producers who
supply them are working around the
clock to keep shelf stocked and the
nation fed supermarkets are recruiting
more staff protecting shopping time for
older and vulnerable people and limiting
shopping hours so they have more time to
restock and I want to take this
opportunity to thank all those staff
working in our supermarkets and food
businesses up and down the country today
who are doing so much to deliver such a
crucial service to us all but as the
Prime Minister has said many times we
need every citizen of this country to
play their part too some supermarkets
have put in place purchase limits on
some items to ensure that there is fair
trading and that their shelves remain
stopped for longer
everyone must respect such measures and
respect the staff working in these shops
who are doing their best to ensure that
both you and your neighbors get the food
supplies that you need thank you I'd
like to pass over to Helen No thank you
thank you I'm just to pick up on a
couple of points there firstly I mean
you don't need you don't need me to tell
you about the the sort of levels of
unprecedented demand that we've all seen
and I really wanted to reassure
everybody that people right across the
food industry from growers packers
producers distributors drivers and the
people right at the front line in our
stores are doing everything they can to
make sure that we have the food food
that we all need and it's almost like
we're seeing basically a peak in demand
like Christmas without the four month
build-up in in planning that you would
normally have in advance and we've been
able to do that in two weeks there is
plenty of food in the supply chain the
issue is around people and lorries so
getting that food right into the front
line onto our shelves which is why we've
seen shortages in some areas across
across lots of different different lines
in different at different areas of the
country what's been vital over the last
few days is the dialogue that we've had
with government they've really listened
carefully to the things that people
across the industry have highlighted
that would make
easier to to increase capacity they've
the there the key is I guess not just
that listening but being able to act
quickly and and George is highlighted
there a couple of things I mean for
example lifting curfew hours for
deliveries has enabled much more lorries
to get through the supply chain and into
stores more quickly and there's a whole
list of things where we've raised an
issue and it's been addressed quickly
and I think that is going to be vital as
we go forward over the over the coming
few weeks and I think the you know the
food retailers that I'm talking to every
on every day and on the call with the
Prime Minister earlier really wanted to
undermine underline that message about
you know in encouraging everybody to
really be considerate in what they buy
make sure that they only buy what they
need there is there is a billion pounds
more food in people's houses than there
was three weeks ago so we should make
sure we yeah we eat some of it and be
considerate and also think about other
people right across your communities and
how we can all help them in making sure
that they can pick up and get their
shopping and so I think it's much more
about how we all work together to to
rise to the challenges that we're facing
Thank You Helen and Steven thank you so
I would just like to make a plea on
behalf of all my colleagues in the NHS
nurses doctors paramedics and many many
others who are working incredibly hard
at the moment to manage this outbreak of
coronavirus are now preparing for the
surge that they know will be coming at
them it's incredibly important that they
to have access to food to those
essential supplies that they need I'm
sure many of you will have seen a video
posted on social media yesterday by Dawn
a critical care nurse who was in tears
at the end of a long shift because she
could not get access to the supplies
that she needed and and frankly we
should all be ashamed that that has to
happen it's unacceptable these are the
very people that we will all need to
look after perhaps
or our loved ones in the weeks ahead
it's critical that by not stockpiling by
not selfishly shopping by leaving those
supplies for others to that our health
workers are able to get access to to
what they need to these are the people
that we will all be relying on more than
we ever have done in the weeks ahead